hi everyone I'm Stephanie poetry and I'm
here with BuzzFeed to talk about my
first times I'm like dreading this
honestly first celebrity you've ever met
um I guess my mom I was in the delivery
room and I turned around I was like oh
hey mom can have a picture no but she's
like pretty big in Indonesia as that's
why I'm singing yeah she inspired me but
like outside of Indonesia um honestly
I've never met anyone and I'm in New
York right now so I don't know why I
haven't seen anyone first concert you
ever attended when I was a kid and my
family for some reason really liked
Linkin Park I was like six and I watch
Linkin Park but the one that I paid for
twice they're so amazing their dances
hey let me go do you know I love white
groups too you know I don't discriminate
first song you sing at karaoke I go with
the classic Bohemian Rhapsody cuz like
you don't even have to sing it on key
and it's still like pretty lit so that's
just how it be sometimes first musical
inspiration I grew up with like a lot of
rock bands and like you look at me now
and you can't tell but it was probably
like My Chemical Romance like I love MCR
first time someone recognized you in
public the first time I got recognized
for my song I love you 3000 I was at the
airport in New York and someone who came
up to me and was like hey I love your
song I was shook you know I didn't think
people like outside of Indonesia knew
but they knew so I mean you really have
to eat first cell phone
I think everyone's first cell phone is
like an Nokia but I got the one that was
like sliding in the back my dad wrote my
name was like a whiteout
so that was iconic and like the white I
would start to like fall off so I had
like a bunch of like remanence of
whiteout on my phone that was not iconic
first album you bought okay okay the
first album I bought with my money my
own money was a got7 album I loved look
their comeback look I just needed album
so you know first app you check in the
morning probably Instagram I talked with
my friends through DM Ola we have like a
group where we just said means I need my
name of the day like that's the first
thing I need you know - laughs first
delivery first celebrity crush
Oh No Oh Sebastian's fans like I said I
saw him on um once upon a time like when
I was really young he was like the Mad
Hatter and I was just like who who is
this man yeah I was except or into him
and he came out as a character in Marvel
I was like oh this mom man I love seeing
people who I used to like Ann decidedly
they're like big again it was nice too
much wrist lyric you wrote on I Love You
3000 I wrote it like through an
Instagram story like for fun I did like
the chorus super quickly I would didn't
know what rhymes with thousand so I went
you know and searched that out and I
found husband so I was like okay I want
you to be my husband yeah I'm not I'm
not good at rhyming so I need help
shout out rhymes ooh first time he
realized your song went viral did it
thing is it kind of grew really like
slowly it was very like organic it
didn't just suddenly boom it was when I
saw on Spotify I was like number one
global viral cuz that I thought that was
just big in Indonesia but really not as
I was like really shocked by that that
was when I thought okay this is real
guys I'm lying to me first time you
performed for an audience I have a funny
story for this I was like for like for
my mom wanted me to sing with her for
like this family thing I was young you
know I was dumb I sang way too quickly
and everyone laughed at me
and yeah that traumatized me for like
years it took like 10 years for me to
just be okay on stage again i'm mechana
as you can sell stuff it's good I don't
hate your mom it's fine
first thing you do when you wake up I
want to say drink water but honestly
it's probably like check my phone cuz I
want to see what time what time it is if
it's early then I probably do nothing
but if I realize it's late then I like
go crazy and go to the bathroom and take
a shower or not I use a lot of perfume
so you never know first time you played
an instrument I learned how to play
piano and I was really young by myself I
didn't even know what u2 was back then
so I was just like pressing keys even
until now I play the piano like this
like a velociraptor but it's my style
it's fine I guess I can't do class like
I can't do like the cool ones so I'm
just like food first song you ever wrote
I remember this super like clearly I was
like nice I wrote a song about a castle
and a princess and I had it in like my
little
notebook honestly it was iconic I should
release it I'm kidding it was so bad but
it was a good starting point because now
I'm here and I'm excited yeah this is
the last one first thing I ate when I
got to America a New York Pizza
cuz we were like super hungry and we
heard like New York pizzas were what so
went and got that it was a I really like
this thank you for having me BuzzFeed it
was really fun to answer questions about
first time maybe after you watch this
video it could be your first time
listening to my song I love you to 8,000
came from my heart to all of you so you
guys enjoy and I'll see you next time
[Music]